[Music]
now thinking about me every night oh is
it that sweet I get so see you can't
sleep baby I know that's that me soul
move it up down left I all switch it up
light Nintendo see you can't sleep baby
I know that's that me is the soul I
can't Rel
to
desperation my give a are on
vacation and I got this one boy and he
won't stop calling when they act this
way I know I got too bad your ex don't
do it for you walked in and dream can't
true it for you skin and I perum it for
you I know I'm not going do it for you
that on coffee for I'm touching up brand
new for
you now he's thinking about me every
night oh that sweet i k so so you can't
sleep baby I know that's that
me move it up
down
lightend see you can't see baby I know
that's that me
is holy
is it that sweet I guess so I'm
working he cuz I'm a singer oh he look
so cute wrapped my finger my twisted
humor Mak him laugh so often my honey be
come and get this ping too bad your ex
don't do it for you walked in and Dream
came true it for you s skin and not
perum for
you yes I know I'm M do for you that
morning coffee for you I'm touching
brand new for
you now he thinking about me
every see you can't see baby I know that
means Soul put it up
down up lightning to know see you can't
seey I know that me is soul think about
me night
s see you can't sleep I know that
me
down L know so you can
[Applause]
see is that sweet I gu
so let time Meo
what up friends I hope you enjoyed that
awesome flow session down at the Kennedy
Center if you'd like to grab a set of
those Popin flow poy that I was using in
this video you can do so by heading on
over to flowtoys.com and using the promo
code Drex Factor
6224 at checkout that is Drex 6220 four
that will get you 10% off your order so
go and check that out thank you so much
to flow toys for sponsoring this video
and giving me a reason to go out and
explore the beautiful spots in DC and
flow out there speaking of thank yous I
have to put out a big thank you to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk flow fests flow toys Pyar
light toys and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
awesome companies and the work they're
doing to support flow artists like
Yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and a
special shout out to the non- business
friend of the channel That is Becca
beonin thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission finally this video and all the
videos on this channel would not exist
without the amazing support of my
supporters on patreon in particular I'd
love to give a shout out to my flow
patrons who are listed on screen right
now thank you all so much for supporting
my channel my work and my mission and if
you out there who are watching this
video are not currently supporters but
would like to become supporters you can
do that by heading on over to my patreon
and signing up at
patreon.com drexfactor poy there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards but better than that you'll be
helping me out in my mission to bring po
spinning and flow Arts to the whole wide
world so go check that out please and
thank you finally if you'd like to check
out more of my flow sessions I will go
ahead and include a link to a playlist
of those videos down in the description
as well as on screen thank you so much
for watching make sure to get out and
Float yourselves today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon take care now
peace